hahaha Oh Jack weird oh it broke Oh God
I look good my glasses you're throwing
it up hang on Lou try this oh maybe my
face is really
oh god is so weird
ah this is all broken
I was not broken maybe we're too close
uh I'm looking at your face or Mike I'm
looking at my face on your face right
yeah what the [ __ ]
that video is still going off yeah okay
wait were you in shut up
Felix my facebook so no but that won't
wait I'm gonna you move my mouth and you
say top okay three two one top of the
morning to you laddies that did not work
happy now I'm looking at your face on -
yeah that is not that's weird
my lovely teeth your face is so squashed
on my face I know the face doesn't move
but the nose my face is heavy on your
hair I have glasses now I know it's
working I guess this is dealing this is
weird nose moves but nothing else does
when you're doing that it's just a
freaky [ __ ] let me do it online
oh no I'm moving but nothing else
Mansion at Disneyland was you're gonna
see tomorrow actually yeah okay any
world and he will like some actor with
your face in my head I'm trying to look
happy on your face it's just not working
you see Oh gigantic your head is no no
you don't make Scott your hands and it
it's just like oh there we go now or
more even
yay I don't know where to look okay
Brighton lens
no u-turns gonna need my lips it's like
that cat video space you finally met
Danny yeah he finally met pani he made
him already know but everybody on that
way we actually got to sit down and have
dinner with him so that was a cool yeah
it was very cool how wait you're doing
the thumbs up when I'm doing this not
okay man but this is so bizarre I keep
looking at my face and expectant smile
well you know I always have bad
self-esteem do not Oh God ah I Ryan hey
hey I do I'm doing pretty good how about
you
whatever just uh waking up right now oh
whoa indeed twins just like it it's
really nice I still look sad you know
what you always do I know what happens
so giving me Chin's oh I can't start
come on in my name is Margo blog Oh
stupid is it look your mouths are big
enough already
get back in here look at the first three
of us had no yeah unfortunately I guess
it would force your plastic surgery good
oh no much freaking out on me Oh
becoming destabilized
I said I was going to go drop someone
off so let's say I'm going to go to did
you get an accent oh my gosh glasses
right I have read the book that's better
a little better a little more casual
smell my teeth oh you're good in white
Oh God
as if my eyebrows couldn't get anything
you guys want to make out with me not at
all not even no god you're mad cool it's
a wheel with M PI mu M PI n pi hence my
senpai it's a dare you
it makes like my beard to take a vortex
into a borehole oddly enough the same
type of skin that's only lives in gel
skin funny bone okay that's enough
now we're going okay bye bye